making Markel and Prince Harry dancing
their way into the hearts of South
Africans on day one of their 10-day
royal tour the Sussex is touched down in
Cape Town early Monday morning after
flying commercial oh she has not been
officially seen there was a paparazzi
shot of him taken at the airport but we
have to wait a few days until we're
going to get an official sighting of the
Royal baby the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex quickly hit the ground running
with a jam-packed day of events stop
number one brought them to me on guitar
shop in Cape Town where the Royals were
all smiles as they arrived hand in hand
at the justest s an organization that
helps women and girls with self-defense
classes in an area known as the murder
capital of South Africa they get update
for a black and white printed maxi dress
from a sustainable Malawi brand which
she paired with wedges the dress retails
at $85 and is already sold out the label
that we saw the Duchess wear today with
my amiko a Malawian based label with an
emphasis on ethical and sustainable
fashion and I think we're going to see
more of that then perhaps the designer
dresses that we're used to seeing the
Duchess wear and that's very much down
to the nature of the trip the people
that they are meeting on this trip
the event was filled with tons of
adorable moments there were high-fives
and cute faces making shared this sweet
embrace with one kiddo
and the Royals dance their hearts out
both Megan and Harry also delivered
powerful speeches I just say that while
I'm here with my husband as a member of
the royal family I want you to know that
for me I am here with you as a mother as
a wife as a woman as a woman of color
and as your sister no man is born to
cause harm to women
this is learned behavior and a cycle
that needs to be broken to me the real
testament of your strength isn't
physical
it's what's up here
no sign of Archie at the event but he
did receive an adorable shirt that reads
be a voice for justice Archie it's just
five months old is being kept in their
official residence under the safe and
watchful eye of his nanny next to the
Sussex is visited the district six
museum in Cape Town which celebrates the
once lively multiracial area that was
destroyed during apartheid back in the
60s and 70s
Megan flipped into a sky blue
button-down dress for the occasion the
same one she sported during last year's
royal tour of the Pacific afterwards
they attended a cooking demonstration
and dinner at the homecoming Center the
Royals will spend the next few days in
Cape Town before Harry heads north to
Botswana Angola and Malawi Megan and
Archie will remain in South Africa the
places that Harry is visiting are simply
too remote and potentially too dangerous
for such a small baby malaria for
example is rife in some of the areas
that Harry will be visiting and the trio
will all reunite in Johannesburg for the
final two days of the tour which ends
October 2nd